por primera vez en la historia en la
quincena de comisarios junto con la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
fontes Legend han viajado a kiev Con un
objetivo claro el de enviar el mensaje
de apoyo inquebrantable de la Unión
Europea a Ucrania un importante mensaje
de calado político habrá reuniones entre
los comisarios y miembros del gobierno
ucraniano que abordarán cuestiones como
que se está haciendo por parte de la
comisión europea para la futura creación
de un tribunal especial en la haya para
investigar los crímenes de guerra por
parte de Rusia también se va a abordar
inevitablemente la futura adhesión de
Ucrania la Unión Europea la comisión
europea insiste en que aún hay que
hacerse mucho más han visto esfuerzos
por parte del gobierno ucraniano sobre
todo en materia de corrupción pero que
aún se debe profundizar mucho más esta
relación y que el gobierno ucraniano a
pesar de las circunstancias debe tomar
aún muchos más pasos en este caso el
gobierno ucraniano insiste en que se
está esforzando y que le gustaría ver al
país como miembro de la Unión Europea en
los próximos tres años esta reunión de
hoy es una previa a la Cumbre entre la
Unión Europea y Ucrania que se va a
producir mañana en kiev con reuniones de
founter Lion y también del presidente
del Consejo europeo Charles Michelle con
el presidente ucraniano
que abordarán como cooperar más entre la
Unión Europea y Ucrania sobre todo desde
que hace ya unos años tiene un acuerdo
de asociación Y cómo poder profundizar
en este acuerdo también va a haber
anuncios concretos Como por ejemplo el
entrenamiento de 15.000 soldados
ucranianos más en territorio comunitario
o también la aprobación final de 500
millones de euros para enviar armas a
Ucrania En definitiva se trata de
reuniones históricas que lo que tratan
es de enviar un mensaje claro de que un
año después de la guerra la Unión
Europea sigue apoyando a Ucrania